but you know your love is not like a
square love yeah
love doesn't really come in the picture
for these yeah because i can't take a
big bag of love to the car lot
or a big bag of love to go pay my
mortgage with you know you need a bag of
money for that
all right big memphis what's going on
over here big memphis
where'd you grow up where are you from
home town to memphis man and tell me
about your family you had both your
parents when you were young uh
nah who uh who raised you
streets man
where was where were mom and dad
all right next question yeah yeah
understood
um how far did you go in school uh 11th
grade
and the in the game came to you at what
what age
about 17 18 17. how did that happen
i mean uh i've always been fascinated by
the
by the by the players and the pimps man
they was always
i like those better than you know it was
just they were more cool than
the drugs building yeah when you were
when you were at that age what options
were there for you for you
selling though robbing pimping and the
pimp's just
yeah and working and i i even i
i sold dope you know i but it just my
heart never was in it
i liked the women yeah the women
it was more fun with the women did you
have somebody to teach you
you know as you as you as you uh as you
step out there off the porch and step
off in the game
you'll you'll get cool with with other
other guys out on the track man and uh
you'll get the passing game along with
one another
and and that's how that'll go you know
in any in any occupation you're gonna
have a friend like i'm pretty sure you
got friends photographers and you know
as you
as you're out there in the same field
every day you're gonna you know it's
gonna be some older guy that's gonna
take a liking to you and go hey young
and this how this go right here
so yeah and that's how to go yeah and uh
tell me about your first girl you you
had oh the first girl i ever had man uh
uh wow man you taking me back a whole
lot of hoes ago
uh uh
yeah the first hoe i ever had man wow
yeah kim a white girl named kim man
yeah uh uh-huh and how's that how'd that
happen how'd she come
how did you guys get together uh when i
when i she
actually she used to buy dough from me
man but uh she just used to buy powder
from
it you know she every time she comes
she's always have a big bank roll but
she was she was working at the strip
club and she used to
she used to like me she's always telling
me you need to let me take care of you
you need to let me take care of you
you know one day i had something that
happened after i lost all my money
shooting dice
and uh she came through wanted to get
some powder and i ain't having i
didn't have no money to get something so
she she gave me the money to she found
me some money to give me some powder
and she gave me some money to put in my
pocket like a thousand put in my pocket
man she told me look man when you get
through with that last dope sack why
don't you just come [ __ ] me let me in
and and man for i i got with her man and
uh
it's like i just never left you know
what i'm saying and that one hoes just
it's just i hear that from so many of
the attempts that
a girl took him under their wing and
showed them the ropes yeah she was
already yeah she was already she was
already stripping i already moved man
and she really liked me you know
yeah that's the key to it the girls the
girl it seems like the girls are always
they're always man uh uh pull you in
well a lot of times
a a guy get turned on to the game you
know hoes get turned out guys get turned
on
and uh uh uh yo yo
yo yo yo a lot of times i've seen weed
guys get turnt on or even the taxi
driver get turned on to the game you
know what i'm saying picking up holes
all the time
he's real cool with the prostitutes he
always out there on the track he's
taking the
[ __ ] to dates and you know i've seen
taxi drivers not guys for their hoes
before
because he could see a [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] with the taxi driver and he
he's telling her you ain't got to give
me all your money you know what i'm
saying i'll take you where you got to go
for free
and one day honda dude might get into it
and if
who she'll call she'll call the taxi
driver he'll let her know you're looking
you got to stay over there at the hotel
you can you can stay in my room i won't
charge you for nothing he'll let him
stay over there for a couple days
you know and i've seen taxi drivers turn
to pimps i've seen it
i just seen it go all kind of ways but a
lot of the time it'll be a woman
that'll turn the pimp on you know and
here memphis it seems to be a really big
thing
yeah yeah yeah the tendon prostate thing
is
it's a big thing memphis memphis is
known for clemson halls memphis memphis
and chicago
yeah memphis and chicago they known for
good pimping at home
and uh you just came back from las vegas
yeah
yeah yeah yeah tell me about what you do
in vegas oh i'm just just i'm just
actually just up that i was on some
businesses
okay so you're not you're not your girls
don't work vegas yeah yeah of course i
work vegas
vegas vegas always pay me vegas is a
good city
vegas can give it to you or can take it
away from you yeah
it done both to me it's been good to me
and took away from it how many girls do
you have
uh two two right now yeah and uh
do you have sex with these girls man i
try i try my best
to to refrain from that you know if you
can wake up and see god every morning he
wouldn't be that amazing to you
so you know you got to try to hold it
for rewards man
you know you want to try to hold effort
for for for
when they when they're doing extra great
and what about drugs are drugs
no i try to i try to stay away from the
drugs you know i try to i like to keep
them clean
but you know out here in this world a
lot of the women
they they're going to do something man
you know because that's
they really have a can you just imagine
man
you know having sex with all those guys
it's got to play some type of mental
stress on you so they kind of need
something to know i mean i i can
understand it
if if if you but i i like them that
when they don't have a drug problem
because see when they when they got drug
problems it uh
it makes them get extra extra cunning
and extra
finish and they they do a lot they tend
to have a lot of lies and a lot of
[ __ ] with them when they get to
messing around on the drugs versus when
they don't do you know smoking a little
weed or something yeah but you almost
need to be
drunk or high to be doing this kind of
work i mean i i can
i can imagine man you know i can put
myself in that [ __ ]
what woman sober is going to say yeah
i've seen the guys these girls pick up
beautiful women
oh my god the bottom of the barrel guys
oh my god unbelievable oh my god
and you're just like you know you know
man and uh i could just imagine
i can imagine you know but you know some
of my folks some of them like it
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy man it's crazy
but it's been going on for a long time
man
you know the only only the only in it
for years it was a victimless crime you
know nobody
really even gave a flying [ __ ] about it
it was a victimless crime until these
kids they start having these
these these these teenagers and and
stuff like that that's when they start
but uh for years it was just a public
eyesore you know
but now you know it's the public enemy
number one yeah especially for the
people for the pimps oh man they're
probably gonna
cops have told me they don't want the
girls they want the people yeah they
want the pillows man they probably give
me number one man
you been arrested uh yeah yeah before
promoting prostitution
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah man you gotta
yeah be careful you gotta be careful man
don't go on youtube and talk about it
man and still be
you got to be careful man what what
style of pimp are you because because
there's many different styles right
it is you've got many different styles
you you somebody introduced me to you as
a gorilla pimp
uh you know
you're six foot four how much you weigh
uh about
220. yeah about 220.
uh a lot of a lot of girls man
you'll run across a lot of girls man
that uh
they've been through so much in their
life they be they they be so
so mentally scarred and so banged up
that they they tough and uh
you know they'll
man they love to fight man they love to
they just they rough man you meet some
rough girls out here man
that i'm too i met some rough chicks man
and
they ain't scared of [ __ ] they don't be
scared of too much
and uh you know a lot of them they they
don't feel like
y'all together unless she's fighting you
or you you kicking on an ass or
something you know it's just
it's crazy man you meet a lot of girls
man it's like that man
you know you'll meet a lot of girls like
that you've been doing this how old are
you now
uh i've been doing this a long time man
over 20 years man
what has it taught you about human
nature about women
man uh it it it's taught me that uh
man you either you either man you're
either a trick or you're a pimp man
you either give him your [ __ ] where you
selling it it's it's one of the two
because when you really look at it
everything a man do is to impress a
woman i don't care how you look at it
you know whether and see with the
prostitute they really paying the woman
to leave
you're not paying her really for the sex
is just just a plus to come with it but
you're really paying her to never call
you
you don't got to see her again and never
nag you and to do what you wanted to do
to fulfill that sexually and get out of
your way
with your wife she's nagging she's you
know
so everything you do is to oppress a
woman you you work you hustle everything
you do is to impress a woman
but with a prostitute you can just pay
her half your way and she can go about a
business
it's taught me that uh
most men are tricks man they love [ __ ]
man
they'll do anything for some [ __ ] what
kind of crazy behavior have you seen
from some of the tricks
man i've some of them
some of them i've seen them fall in love
with i've seen some tricks man that uh
he's not happy unless a trick a [ __ ] is
stealing his money
he lays it out just for a bit to steal
it uh
you know some of them not happen unless
they getting [ __ ] or pissed on
so it's just all kind of
man it's crazy man but it is what it is
it's the world win right
yeah that's what it is does intimidation
or violence ever come into the picture
for you
uh you you i mean if your girl gets a
little head strong or gets it ain't
about his
like i said a lot of them a lot of them
will start you know especially when they
come in and drunk man they'll come in
just ready to fight you know they come
in ready to fight man you feel them they
come in
they they lit they ready to fight they
got their shoes off they wig off and
these [ __ ] ready to fight they got a
knife they got a maze they got
yeah so you're gonna defend yourself i'm
telling you man i'm telling you you run
across some crazy women
in the streets make them yeah yeah
yeah i think i think alcohol or drugs
alcohol changes your personality
alcohol bad [ __ ] man yeah
there's some girls i've interviewed who
your heart opens up and you just want to
like
hug them and save them but then three
hours later you got like this [ __ ]
you she's a different person yeah man
she's got nine different personalities
so you you ever been on left
nah nah man i've been i've been messing
with prostitutes so long uh
yeah you know but uh uh i i i can have a
love for
you know the pills love for a whole is
is different you know
i you know you have a [ __ ] been around
for a while y'all doing a lot of stuff
together you know you you love what
you're doing for you you know
y'all having a good time traveling the
world getting money
so uh but you know your love is not like
a square love
yeah love doesn't really come in the
picture for these yeah because i can't
take a big bag of love to the car lot
or a big bag of love to go pay my
mortgage with you know you need a bag of
money for that have any of these women
ever like
turn their lives around and live the
square life yeah and i have them on some
i'm gonna come back to they're called
three four five years later it's just
not working out i was just wondering if
you were still in the game
yeah i'm still in everybody you know
what i'm saying you know they want to
get with it you know repeat offenders
and stealing from tricks is part of the
game for a lot of these girls a lot of
steel yeah
yeah yeah a lot of them hustlers yeah a
lot of them they're gonna steal
yeah what what kind of girl what
personality traits do you look for
uh uh what qualities
man i'm looking for i'm smart
go-getter a listener that's what i'm
really looking for man
some of these girls are just not cut out
for this kind of some of them not and
when they're not cut out you just got to
let them go
yeah you know because messing around
with them you have a human trafficking
child so yeah
they'll cost you man so you know if it
ain't working just let them go
yeah did you have kids yeah you got two
sons
you raised me yeah they grown my son's
grown man
they're following dad's footsteps no no
they're not actually
they know what dad does yeah they know
what do they think of that they think
it's the greatest thing
they think you know they're cool yeah
so do you think the prostitute's
relationship with a pimp is is based on
like recreating what she had with her
father which was a lot of them are
looking for the father syndrome you know
a lot of you guys daddy
yeah well that's where it comes from you
know because of the instructions that
you give them what you're teaching them
you know
but in a lot of them uh
uh i don't care what they call me long
they don't call me broke you know
i ain't really hung up on the got to
call me daddy thing but it just happens
you know it flows better because i call
them mom hey mom
so you know that just kind of flows off
their tongue and you know once they
learn
with you and learning from you and
you're teaching them a lot of good stuff
man and
you know you know you the first first
flight they've been on
first time they you know done a lot of
things man you know uh
so they tend to call your daddy for that
respect just out of respect thing
so the girl brings you 100 of her money
uh i mean
i i would hope so and then what does she
get
well whatever she needs yeah whatever
she needs
right you know you know what she can't
have what what's a what's an honest
guess at what these girls make at night
you know it's hard i hear all kinds of
people yeah
yeah you really okay it's hard to say
man it's hard to say
you know i try not to put a capcom on it
man so you really
just give it all you got you know but
here in memphis what's with if if i if
if a guy was to pick up a girl
for like like an hour
of of fun with her what what would what
would that cost a guy
a hundred dollars hundred feet at all
yeah yeah
yeah she'll end up doing this three four
five six seven eight times a day
yeah if it's rolling if if if it's going
good
yeah yeah if it's going good
yeah i like i like you know it's got
some you got some good cities that
give it up real good but yeah you know
if if they're coming back to back like
that
it's going to get them and do you ever
feel any guilt or
anything about having these girls do
this for you so you can just sit back
and collect the money
no no your name's already in the mix now
so no
no you feel like you provided service i
mean
you give them guidance yeah you give a
guy you give him when she first mentions
everything she had was all you know in a
bind everything she shown was in a cvs
bag now she got she came in counter bags
she can't even counter heels she can't
even
you know she didn't even know how to eat
lobsters and that's she's eating
lobsters and crawling so
i feel like you know you you yeah you
showing this as well to be done right
here yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
at the end of the day the only thing
that matters what the county is man
you know and what the county is it's all
about it at the end of the day man
all right big memphis man it's been a
pleasure man thank you so much for
sharing your story been a pleasure my
man wish you the best of luck out there
you too my man take care of your girls
it's been a pleasure my man